es ist die Schatzkammer Sachsens das
Dresdner Grüne Gewölbe ausgeraubt am 25
November 2019
die Täter erbeuten Millionenwerte wie
den 50 karätigen sächsischen weißen
Diamanten der sächsische weiße der
größte Stein der Sammlung der ist damals
für 200.000 Taler angekauft worden das
entspricht ungefähr zwei Tonnen Gold ein
Jahr ermittelt eine Soko dann führen
Spuren ins kleinen Milieu die Einbrecher
selbst hatten Hinweise am Grünen Gewölbe
hinterlassen da muss man ehrlich sein
wir haben sie auch nicht mit den
absoluten kognitiven Leuchten zu tun hat
die hinterlassen im Regelfall und Tatort
Orten auf vier dNA Spuren vom Schmuck
aber fehlt lange jede Spur bis die
Einbrecher anbieten Rückgabe gegen straf
Nachlass einen Deal also doch Deals sind
umstritten
hat im Hinterzimmer werden die Strafen
ausgehandelt und dann im Urteil nur noch
verkündet
mit dem trist der Urteil endet die
Geschichte dieses Einbruchs dass die
meisten der Angeklagten ins Gefängnis
müssen damit hatten sie gerechnet die
Frage war wie lange denn sie hatten
gestanden und sie hatten die Beute
zurückgebracht nur eben beschädigt und
unvollständig offenbar sein sie für den
Deal keine andere Wahl
diese Verständigung ist aus meiner Sicht
nur vor dem Hintergrund zu sehen dass es
sich im Laufe des Prozesses doch eine
Verurteilung als immer wahrscheinlicher
angesehen hat und das ist dann die
Verteidigung war die Ende November
letzten Jahres dann auf die
Staatsanwaltschaft zugegangen ist ob man
noch mal ins Gespräch kommen könne ob im
Falle eines Geständnisses und der
Rückgabe des Schmuckes in milderes
Strafmaß möglich sei am Ende standen
Haftstrafen zwischen vier und gut sechs
Jahren einen der Angeklagten sprach das
Gericht frei er hatte ein Alibi es ist
der Schlussstrich unter einen
jahrhundert drauf die beiden Täter die
hier wie von Sinnen auf Vitrinen im
Grünen Gewölbe einschlagen und brauchen
nur Minuten um 21 Kollektionen an sich
zu reißen besetzt mit 4.300 Diamanten
allein der Versicherungswert liegt bei
über 16 Millionen Euro der größte Stein
der Beute der sächsische weiße besaß
damals schon und fassbaren wert
der sächsische Weise der größte Stein
der Sammlung der ist damals führt
200.000 Taler angekauft worden das
entspricht ungefähr zwei Tonnen Gold am
Dresdner Schloss in der Innenstadt
finden sich bis heute Spuren des
Einbruchs von vor dreieinhalb Jahren
provisorisch repariert ist auch das
herausgesetzt Dreieck im originalen
Fenstergitter zu erkennen die
Kameratechnik erneuert das Museum
drinnen beherbergt Kunstschätze von
unsagbarem historischen Wert
zusammengetragen vor über 300 Jahren vom
sächsischen König August der Starke
August der Starke hatte eigentlich
verschiedene Motivationen das eine war
wirkliche Passion zum anderen war es
natürlich herrschaftliche Repräsentation
und der stand immer im Wettbewerb
besteht immer auf Ludwig den 14 und
wollte viel viel mehr Garnituren haben
als dieser und das dritte war letztlich
auch und können sagen finanzielle
Rücklage also so eine Art Schatz den hat
damit bilden konnte
bei aller Planung hatten die Diebe eines
offenbar nicht bedacht wie sich eine
solche weltberühmte Beute auf dem Markt
zu Geld machen lässt es blieb Raum für
Spekulationen ich kann mir gar nicht
vorstellen dass diese Schmuckstücke ohne
einen Kunden gestohlen wurden also
einfach auf den Markt zu gehen und sie
frei anzubieten das geht natürlich
überhaupt nicht man würde die
Schmuckstücke sofort erkennen sofort
ein Jahr lang ermittelt die SOKO
epilette im Stillen dann der
Paukenschlag im November 2020 über 1.600
Beamte durch kämmen Wohnungen einer
arabisch stämmigen Großfamilie in Berlin
die Beute finden Sie nicht mutmaßliche
Täter schon aber immer Gruppen mit den
kaum Zusammenarbeit möglich ist sie sich
kaum den deutschen Sprache
Verfolgungsbehörden öffnen die also in
einer Parallelwelt weitgehend leben also
auch archaische strukturiert sind auch
Benjamin Jennifer von der Gewerkschaft
der Polizei in Berlin hat damals wenig
Hoffnung dass Klan Mitglieder je zur
Kooperation bewegt werden könnten es
geht mir an die Risse Richtung wirklich
spektakuläre Straftaten worüber auch
jeder redet ja es geht auch salopp
gesagt darum zu zeigen wer hat
eigentlich den größten und wer kann
eigentlich das größte Ding starten ja
aber es geht dann eben auch um Prestige
das Geld ist das eine ja man muss aber
schon sagen dass das Schmiermittel der
organisierten Kriminalität sind
Drogengeschäft also man braucht diese
Kurs jetzt nicht unbedingt um sich den
Kriminellen Lebenswandel dann auch zu
finanzieren aber klar wenn sie irgendwo
einsteigen und sie klauen was was 100
Millionen wert ist dann sind sie ja
gemacht der Mann ne und dann gehen sie
auch mal fünf Jahre ins Gefängnis dafür
weil danach kommen sie raus und jeder
sagt man krass dass du das damals
durchgezogen hast im Januar 2022 beginnt
der Prozess bei dem immer mehr Details
ans Licht kommen Details die für eine
gründliche Planung sprechen
im Vorfeld soll bereits ein Teil des
Fenster geht das herausgesägt und dann
wieder mittels Klebeband eingefügt
worden sein um am Tag möglichst schnell
das Gebäude gelangen zu können sechs
Angeklagte stehen in Dresden vor dem
Richter sie und die Verteidiger zeigen
sich äußerst selbstbewusst das soll sich
im Prozess Verlauf noch ändern
zu Beginn war es so dass die Anwälte
schon relativ selbstsicher wirkten und
gelegentlich doch mal so ein bisschen
die stichelt haben das ist ja hier wohl
die falschen auf der Anklagebank sitzen
die Ermittlungen zeigen aber dass die
Angeklagten mit zwei Autos aus Berlin
anreisen eins parken Sie in einer
Tiefgarage das andere bringt sie zum
Tatort dort entzündeten sie ein
Stromkasten und dringend ins Grüne
Gewölbe ein das alles dauert nur wenige
Minuten doch die Täter waren zumindest
juristisch schlecht beraten ein
Fluchtauto stecken sie in der Tiefgarage
in Brand und gefährden Menschen leben
damit aber schrauben sie unwissentlich
ihr Strafmaß drastisch nach oben
der Tatverlauf besonders schweren
brandstift und gründet hier insbesondere
darin dass die Tat zu Verdeckung einer
anderen Straftat eingesetzt wurde da
sagt das Gesetz besonders schwere
Brandstiftung mit einem Strafraum von 5
bis 15 Jahren
die Einbrecher erreichen schon am frühen
Morgen wieder Berlin das Fluchtauto
stellen sie später am Straßenrand ab der
Tathergang zeigt Parallelen zum Einbruch
ins Berliner Bode-Museum von 2017 eine
100 kg schwere Goldmünze bleibt bis
heute verschwunden einer der Einbrecher
der nun in Dresden für den Einbruch ins
Grüne Gewölbe verurteilt wurde stand
auch für den Goldmünzen Raub in Berlin
vor Gericht 2019
während sie eigentlich auf einer
Anklagebank für eine andere schwere
Straftat sitzen ja und da muss man schon
fragen ist da noch eine Resozialisierung
wirklich so möglich oder eigentlich eher
nicht im Prozessverlauf verdichten sich
indes Indizien und Beweise so
präsentiert die Staatsanwaltschaft auch
dNA Spuren der Einbrecher vom Tatort im
Museum hatten sie noch Handschuhe
getragen draußen dann offenbar nicht
mehr
da muss man ehrlich sagen wir haben sie
auch nicht mit den absoluten kognitiven
Leuchten zu tun hat die hinterlassen im
Regelfall und Tatort und auch viel dNA
Spuren so und wenn wir jemanden schon
mehrfach verurteilt haben oder der immer
wieder seine DNA irgendwo hinterlassen
hat dann ist auch irgendwann einfacher
für Sicherheit ja und die sind dann halt
schon auf dem Raster und dann schaut man
sich die an der Schmuck aber bliebt
verschwunden im ganzen gelten die
Diamanten in den Kollektionen als
unverkäuflich aber einzeln auch das ist
kompliziert den anders als zum Beispiel
eine Goldmünze lassen sich Diamanten
eben nicht einfach ein schmelzen
also wenn man jetzt diese Schmuckstück
umarbeiten würde und dann einzeln zu
Geld machen würde zum Beispiel das
Material Einschmelzen oder die Steine
umschleifen lassen das wäre ein immenser
Wertverlust und das wäre bestimmt nicht
im Sinne dieses Raubes gewesen ganz
bestimmt nicht der Schmuck kaum
verkäuflich oder weniger wert die
erdrückende Beweislast und die drohende
hohe Haft wahrscheinlich führt all das
zum Umdenken auf der Anklagebank kurz
vor Weihnachten geben die Einbrecher
große Teile der Beute zurück gegen die
Zusage einer Strafmilderung ein Deal
also natürlich legal in Fachkreisen
trotzdem umstritten
hat im Hinterzimmer werden die Strafen
ausgehandelt und dann im Urteil nur noch
verkündet das geht eigentlich nicht aber
eigentlich soll soll ich auch das ganze
Ergebnis in öffentlichen Verhandlung
zustande kommen um den Deal jedoch gab
es ein csringen weil der Schmuck eben
teils beschädigt war und unvollständig
die sogenannte Verfahrens Absprache
hatten vorher manche Medien auch als
Skandal kritisiert das Gericht dann bei
der Urteilsbegründung zum die Stellung
der Richter sagte es sei ein probates
Mittel gesetzlich verankert und ein
Skandal wäre es eher gewesen dieses
Mittel nicht auszuschöpfen denn dann
wären die Juwelen wahrscheinlich niemals
wieder nach Dresden zurückgekehrt
das Urteil ist gefallen ob es die
Angeklagten Anerkennung oder
Rechtsmittel einlegen ist zur Stunde
noch offen genau wie noch andere Fragen
wo sind die Schmuckstücke die noch
fehlen welcher Schaden ist entstanden
und wie wird dieser Schaden beglichen
das bedeutet dass der Freistaat Sachsen
sein
Schadensersatzansprüche dann im Rahmen
eines Zivilprozesses Geld machen kann
und muss die Geschichte um den
sogenannten jahrhundert darauf findet
also womöglich eine Fortschreibung die
bis jetzt zurückgegebenen Stücke werden
repariert und sobald wie möglich dann
auch wieder ausgestellt